[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يقول ناشطون سوريون ان اشتباكات
عنيفه تتواصل بين كتائب المعارضه المسلحه
والجيش النظامي في محاور من احياء حمص
المحاصره واقام مسلحون ترابيه لصد اجتياح
مرتقب من قبل قوات النظام نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما هي اهميه حمص العسكريه في
حسابات المعارضه
والنظام وما هي موازين القوى التي تحكم
المواجهه
[موسيقى]
فيها السواتر الترابيه هو ربما اخر ما بقي
للمعارضه المسلحه في مدينه حمص القديمه
لمنع قوات النظام من اجتياح محتمل فقد
اخفقت الوساطات المحليه والدوليه في تامين
فك الحصار عن المدينه ما اغرى النظام
بالحسم العسكري بعد انهاك بالحصار والقصف
على مدى اكثر من
عامين ليست اصوات طلقات ناريه احتفالا
بجلاء المستعمر الفرنسي عن سوريا فهذه هي
احياء حمص القديمه المحاصره منذ اكثر من
عامين التي تستعد قوات النظام
لاقتحامها يصادف هذا اليوم عيد الجلاء في
سوريا جلاء
لمستعمرة
وتحسبا لهجمات قوات النظام بهدف اقتحام
المدينه القديمه تعمل كتائب المعارضه على
وضع السواتر الترابيه في الخطوط الاماميه
ومداخل
الاحياء في ريف حمص تعاني مدينه التلبيسه
من القصف الجوي المستمر عليها منذ ايام
الاطفال هنا هم العنوان الابرز للجرحى
والقتلى في مستشفيات المدينه اما في بلده
الغنطو فتستقر قذائف الهاون على الاحياء
السكنيه التي تقصفها قوات النظام كذلك في
الدار
اشتباكات بين كتائب المعارضه وقوات النظام
في قريه الخالديه التابعه لها تلك هي
حكايه حمص عاصمه الثوره السوريه تنتظر
مصيرها خلال الساعات
القادمه في ضوء ترقب وهواجس من بقي فيها
من سكان وحيره من ردود فعل المجتمع الدولي
وهو يرقب الام ويوميات هذه
المدينه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو حمزه المصطفى الباحث في المركز
العربي للابحاث ودراسه السياسات كما ينضم
الينا من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي فيصل عبد
الساتر وعبر سكايب من حي الوعر في حمص
الناشط الحقوقي وعضو شبكه سوريا مباشر
الاخباريه محمد الحميد اهلا بضيوفي الكرام
وابدا بضيفي
في استوديو استاذ حمزه
المصطفى ما الذي تعنيه حمص في الحسابات
لدى النظام عندما يقوم بما يقوم به الان
وقد كان بالامكان ان يتم الاتفاق وينسحب
المسلحون ويخرج المدنيون ويبسط السيطره
على حمص القديمه ا منذ بدايه منذ منتصف
العام
2013 النظام توفرت لديه قناعه بان سوريا
بكامل جغرافيتها جغرافيتها لم تعد متاحه
لسيطرته لذلك عمد على الى تبديل خياراته
واستراتيجيته واقر كما
يقول المسؤولين السوريين في م قدمتهم بشار
الاسد يلمح بشكل غير مباشر الى ان
الاهتمام اصبح بالمركز سوري او ما يسميه
بعض المحللين القريبين من نظام سوريا
المفيده القريبه من التي تمتد من دمشق
كمركز سياسي
العاصمه وصولا الى المنطقه الوسطى مع
امتداد الى المنطقه الساحليه حيث المنفذ
البحري حمص هي واسطه هي هي قلب هذه
المنطقه بكل ما تعنيه في هذه المنطقه وجه
النظام عده تحديات التحدي الاول كان فيما
يتعلق
ب النشاط العسكري لقوات المعارضه في
القلمون ومنذ معركه القصير منتصف 2013
وحتى معركه يبرود الاخيره بالاستعانه مع
ميليشيات حزب الله وميليشيات عراقيه اخرى
تمكن النظام من السيطره على مرحله على
معركه القلمون
وبعد ان سيطر ايضا على ريف حمص الجنوبي
تمكن ايضا بالاستفاده من الدعم الذي قدمه
حزب الله من السيطره على قلعه الحصن في
ريف حمص الغربي وبالتالي سقط الريف الريف
الحمصي بشكل كامل باستثناء الريف الشمالي
وبعض المواقع في الريف الشرقي ما ما اغرى
قوات النظام الى كسر الهدن التي ا تم
التفاهم عليها في الجوله الثانيه من مؤتمر
جنيف برعايه امميه وبدا بعمليه الاقتحام
الحاليه
لانهاء اخر بؤره ما يعتبره اخر بؤره مسلحه
للمعارضه واخر رمزيه للثوره حقيقه في حمص
في احياء حمص عن المعارضه وهنا سؤالي موجه
لسيد فيصل عبد الساتر ما تخسر المعارضه
بسيطره قوات النظام على معظم حمص حتى
الان عفوا ا السؤال اذا سمحت سالتك ما
الذي تخسره المعارضه بسيطره قوات النظام
على معظم حمص ونتكلم عن الخساره بالمفهوم
العام بال بين المعارضه والسلطه فيما
يتعلق بعموم
سوريا يعني الخساره في حمص هي كالخس التي
تكبتها الجماعات المسلحه في سوريا في كل
المناطق السوريه وحمص ايضا من ضمن هذه
المناطق حيث تعتبر هذه الجماعات المسلحه
ان سيطرتها على حمص فيما مضى من الزمان
كان بمثابه يعني المحاوله استراتيجيه
لتقطيع اوصال سوريا بما ان محافظه حمز
لديها حدود ثلاثه مع يعني المحافظات
الشماليه والمحافظات الساحليه ومع لبنان
والعراق من جهه اخرى لذلك هذه العمليه
الان تهدف الى فصل المسار بشكل نهائي
وبدايه عوده حمص الى حضن الدوله والى حضن
الشرعيه وان المعارضه المسلحه يعني عليها
ان تفهم هذه الرساله انها بعد خساره كل
المواقع في القلمون منذ القصير الى الى
رنكوس الى الزبداني يعني في اليومين
المقبلين سوف لن يكون لها اي ظهر ولا اي
يعني منطقه تستطيع ان تؤمن لها معبرا
لوجستيا وبالتالي عليها ان تحدد يعني
لنفسها خيار من اثنين اما الاستسلام
والقبول بمنطق العفو الذي ممكن ان يصدر
بعد ذلك واما ان تقاتل حتى تلقى حتفها طيب
سيد محمد الحميد الناشط الحقوقي من حي
الوعر في حمص هناك حديث عن اعاده ترتيب
للعناصر البشريه في حمص اعاده التركيبه
السكانيه في حمص ايضا بالتوازي مع ما يجري
من خطوات عسكريه ماذا عن هذه
النقطه سيدي الكريم بالنسبه لاعاده
الترتيب السكان في مدينه حمص فهذه عمليه
بدا فيها النظام منذ بدايه الثوره حتى
نستطيع ان نقول منذ بدايه عهد حكم ال
الاسد لسوريا ف ببدايه عهد ال الاسد في
حكم سوريا بدا النظام السوري بزرع ما
نسميه مستوطنات حول مدينه حمص رويدا رويدا
تحولت الى احياء وتجمعات سكانيه تحولت هذه
التجمعات السكانيه التي جميع سكانها من
طيف واحد محسوبا على النظام السوري تحولت
جميع سكان هؤلاء الى ان يشكلوا 30% من
سكان مدينه حمص في حين لم يكن لهم اي نسبه
من قبل في المدينه عندما بدات الثوره
السوريه يبدو ان الفرصه اصبحت مواتيه
لتطبيق ان يصبح هذه المجموعات تشكل غالبيه
مدينه حمص فبدا النظام اولا ب عمليات
القصف بهدف التهجير ثم بدا لم لم تنجح هذه
العمليات ثم بدا بارتكاب المجازر عن طريق
شبيحته هؤلاء الشبيحه الذين بداوا
بالمجازر بدء من اجتياح باب عمر وارتكاب
مجازر فيها ثم مجزره كرم الزيتون الشهيره
ثم توالت المجازر رويدا رويدا في الاحياء
وذلك في بعد الشهر الثاني من عام
2012 تتابعت المجازر مما ادى الى نزوح
كبير للسكان من حوالي 28 حيا من الاحياء
في مدينه حمص هذا هذا التهجير القصري الذي
تم من قبل النظام اما باستخدام القصف او
استخدام المجازر ادى الى تغيير ديموغرافي
الان مؤقت في المدينه ولكن النظام اتبع
ذلك بخطوات اخرى منها احراق السجل العقاري
في المدينه الذي باحراقه يخفي
كافه وثائق ملكيه لمن يريد المطالبه
بملكيته باراضي داخل مدينه حمص نحن نعلم
ان هناك تقارير صدرت عن منظمات كثيره تقول
ان النظام السوري يسعى الى
تجنيس مقاتلين معه من خارج سوريا داخل
سوريا واصدر كثير من الناشطون بيان بيانات
منها بيان شباب السويداء الذين اصدروا
بيانا ان النظام يقوم بتجنيس اشخاص لديهم
في باسم عائلات في محافظه سويداء ولكن هذا
الامر يسحب ايضا ال على مدينه حمص فنظام
يقوم بعمليات تجنيس لمقاتلين معه هذا
التجنيس يريد النظام ان يسكن هؤلاء في
الاحياء وهذا تم وفعلا الان هناك من يسكن
حي باب عمر هناك من يسكن حي باب سباع هناك
من يسكن جزء من حيبا الدريب الذي سيطر
عليه النظام هناك من يسكن جبه جندلي احياء
التي سيطر عليها النظام النظام يريد اتمام
عمليته ب اتمام السيطره على احياء القديمه
وحي جورت شياح والقصور والقرابيص هذه
الاحياء التي ما زال فيها عناصر تابعه
للجيش الحر
المنطقه تحارب عن وجوها طيب استاذ حمزه
المصطفى دائما في هذا السياق سياق اهميه
حمص ومساله تغيير التركيبه البشريه في هذه
المدينه او هذه الم المحافظه بالاضافه الى
ما يجري من عمليات عسكريه كيف يمكن جعل
هذا الامر واقعي في ظل ما يراه او ما يخطط
له النظام في سوريا فيما فيما يت فيما
يتعلق ب بعمليه التغيير الديموغرافي وانا
اسميه تغيير ديموغرافي ممنهج في الحقيقه
هو ليس تغيير ديموغرافي في حمص فقط بل في
جميع انحاء سوريا على اعتبار اذا اخذنا
الاحصائيات دوليه 4 مليون لاجئ و9 مليون
مقتلع نجد ان اكثر من نصف سكان س اصبحوا
خارج سوريا اما فيما يتعلق بحمص ف فقد
تطرق الاخ من حمص الى الى العمليات التي
جرت حقيقه منذ ومنذ منتصف الستينيات مع
سيطره حزب البعث العربي الاشتراكي على
السلطه من خلال بناء المواقع العسكريه ومن
ثم التمدد في الاحياء الى ان اصبحت هذه
الاحياء تشكل تشكل جزء كبيرا من المدينه
وهو الحقيقه انه التغيير الديموغرافي بدا
او كان هناك مخططات او او ما شابه ذلك قبل
لبدايه الثوره كل الجميع في حمص يعرف عن
مشروع حلم حمص وعن استملاك الاراضي في
الميماس والبساتين ومشروع تدمر ولل
المفارقه بمكان ان اول شعار خرج في حمص
بدايه الثوره الشعب يريد اسقاط المحافظ
هذا لان المحافظ كان يمثل الطبقه
النيوليبراليه المتحالفه مع
طبقه الضباط العلويين الموجودين الاحداث
وكما تحدث منذ بدايه الثوره يعني منذ
بدايه الثوره بدات بدا بشكل او
باخر هذا النهج ف فمنذ بدايه عام 2012 على
سبيل المثال وما رافقت عمليات
الاقتحام كان الجيش السوري يصطحب ميليشيات
طائفيه وكان يغض الطرف بشكل بشكل مباشر
على المجازر وعلى سبيل المثال اريد فقط
فقط ان اذكر اهم المجازر التي ارتكبت على
اساس طائفي فعلى سبيل المثال مازرت كرم
الزيتون ومزر حي الرفاعي ومزر حي الشماس
الاول ومزر حي الشماس الثانيه ومزر خربه
السودا في ريف حمص ومزر باتين البع اضافه
الى المز مزره الحوله الشهيره والتي حم عن
هذه الاتهامات الموجهه للنظام بالتوجه
طائفيا في رسم واقع جديد لس هنا اسال ضيفي
في بيروت استاذ فيصل عبد الساتر الا يورط
النظام نفسه بهذه السياسه حمص نموذجا
تغيير تركيبه بشريه لمصلحه طائفه على حساب
بالشعب
السوري
يا اخي انا استغرب يعني كيف ان هذه اللغه
وهذا الخطاب لازال هو هو منذ بدايه الازمه
السوريه البعض يصر على استعمال اللغه
المذهبيه والطائفيه وكان هناك مكونات من
خارج سوريا اتت الى سوريا عندما نتحدث عن
مكونات الشعب السوري سواء من علويين او
دروز او مسيحيين او ايزيديين او كرد وعرب
اليسوا هؤلاء من الشعب السوري الا يسمح
للشعب السوري بان يتنقل بين مدينه واخرى
وان يشتري املاك في مدينه واخرى وان يعني
يكون له محلات وشقق سكنيه هذا المنطق
يذكرني بالمنطق الاسرائيلي يعني كاننا
نتحدث الان وكان الدوله في سوريا هي
استيطانيا وهي تحاول ان تستوعب مستوطنات
على حساب بعض السكان الاصليين هذا كلام
خطير لا ينم الا عن رائحه طائفيه ومذهب لا
اعتقد ان النظام في سوريا كان في يوم من
الايام يتكلم باسم طائفيه او مذهبيه هو
نظام علم مي وحزب البعث هو يعني اذا كان
لديه من نقاط قوه لازالت تحترم في سوريا
وفي العالم العربي من انه حزب علماني لا
ينادي ابدا لا بطائف ولا بمذهب هذا من
ناحيه و ناحيه ثانيه عندما نتحدث عن تغيير
ديموغرافي كيف لمكون يعني لا يعتبر شيء
بالنسبه للعدد الاكبر من مكونات الشعب
السوري ان يعني يكون له هذه الاكثريه
الراجحه في مدن كبيره مثل مدينه حمص او
مدينه حلب او مدينه دمشق هذا كلام يعني
ممكن يعني ان يتلى على بعض صغار العقول
فيصدقها اما الذين لديهم عقول راجحه لا
يمكن ان يصدقوا مثل هذه الاكاذيب لا من
قريب ولا من بعيد ثم الحديث عن المجازر
عندما نتحدث عن المجازر اخر من يحق له عن
الحديث عن المجازر هي الجماعات المسلحه
التي تسمي نفسها معارضه في سوريا هي التي
ارتكبت اكبر مجزره في تاريخ سوريا في ريف
اللاذقيه وارتكبت ابع افزع الجرائم في
حماه وارتكبت افزع الجرائم في تلدو وفي
بانياس وفي العديد من المناطق وكلها كانت
تحت عنوان طائفي ومذهبي الا ان الشعب
السوري رفض هذا النهج الطائفي والمذهبي
وقال ان كل الذين قتلوا هم من ابناء سوريا
وبالتالي هذا ال الذي حدث هو خساره على كل
سوريا اما ان نستعمل اللغه المذهبيه فماذا
ي يقولون الان عن الاف الشيشانيين والاف
التونسيين والليبيين والعراقيين وعناصر
حزب الله والايرانيين الى غير ذلك اذا في
الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه سوف نناقش
مساله موازين القوى في حمص وكيف لها ان
تحدد ما يجري الان ان كان مؤقتا ام انه
حاسما لفريق على حساب الفريق الاخر بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الح
الحلقه التي تناقش الوضع في مدينه حمص
السوريه في ظل تواصل القصف والاشتباكات
بين المعارضه والمسلحه وبين النظام واتوجه
بسؤالي الان الى ضيفي من حي الوعر في حمص
الناشط الحقوقي محمد الحميد سيد محمد ما
مدى تاثير ما يجري الان على صعيد التركيبه
السكانيه في حمص على صعيد موازين القوى
بين النظام وبين
المعارضه سيد الكريم نجري الان في مدينه
حمص نستطيع ان نقول انه الخطوه يريد ان
يخطوها النظام في سبيل سيطره طيف كامل على
مدينه ضمه مث مثل مدينه حمص التي تشكل
ثالث مدينه في ترتيب المدن السوريه من حيث
الضخامه الاقتصاديه والسكانيه النظام يريد
ان يخطو في هذه المدينه التي يعلم
السوريين جميعا انها تمتلك ثلثي ثقل
القرار السوري السياسي والاقتصادي من خلال
السيطره لمجموعه واحده من مجموعات الشعب
السوري على القرا في سوريا وهي تابعه
للنظام السوري نحن لا نريد ان نتكلم بطائف
لا نريد ان نتكلم لان الشعب السوري لا
يمتلك هذه هذه الصفات وانما من اجبر الشعب
السوري على الكلام بها هو النظام السوري
من خلال تصرفاته من خلال العمليات التي
يقوم بها في هذه المدينه فمثلا العمليه
الاخيره التي يريد بها النظام السوري يريد
ان يسيطر على ما تقريبا 14 حيا يسيطر
عليها الجيش الحر ح في هذه الاثناء النظام
السوري يريد ان يسيطر على هذه الاحياء كي
يتم سيطرته على الجزء الاكبر من مدينه حمص
وبهذا الكلام نستطيع ان نقول ان اكثر من
800000 نسمه من سكان مدينه حمص اصبحوا بلا
ماوى سيطر النظام على مبانيهم لن يعودوا
الى هذه المباني طالما ان النظام سيطر
عليهم لان جميع سكان هذه الاحياء هم
مطلوبون للنظام بشكل او باخر لان النظام
اصبح في الفتره الاخيره ونحن نع واصدرت
المنظمات الدوليه عده بيانات قالت فيها ان
النظام السوري يقوم بالاعتقال على الهويه
كل من له هويه مثلا نتكلم عن حي مثل حي
باب عمر الاعتقال على الهويه حي مثل
خالديه حي مثل جورج شياح مثل رابيس يعتقل
النظام على الهويه لن يسمح لسكان هذه
الاحياء بالعوده الى احيائهم فهذه العمليه
العسكريه التي يقوم بها النظام هي الخطوه
الاخيره التي يعتقد انه من خلالها سوف
يسيطر على مدينه حمص ديمغرافيا مغيرا فيها
التركيبه السكانيه نحن نعلم ان اكثر من
800 الف نسمه من مدينه حمص اصبحوا الان
مهجرين اغلبهم
مهجرين في خارج
البلاد النصف الاخر منهم مهجر داخل حي
دعني افصل ايضا في هذه النقطه سيد محمد
نعم مع ضيفي هنا في استاذ حمزه المصطفى
استمعت الاستاذ فيصل عبد الساتر يقول من
المستحيل تغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في
حمص بالنظر الى انه ولو اراد النظام لان
التركيبه السكانيه واضحه اغلبيه سنيه مع
اقليه علويه وبالتالي لماذا المبالغه في
هذا الموضوع واثارته بهذا الشكل عندما
يتعلق الامر بحمص واهميتها وموازين القوى
بين الطرفين يعني بدايه انا
استغرب نقد تشريح الواقع مع الايحاءات ب
بشرحه على اساس تقسيمات السوسيولوجيه
الموجوده للمجتمع السوري والسكوت عن الفعل
الطائفي الممنهج الذي يحصل حقيقه ولا اقصد
هنا فعل طائفي ممنهج من قبل النظام في حمص
فقط النظام استطاع ان على سبيل المثال في
في ساحات اخرى ان يخفف من وطئه الاستقطاب
الطائف الموجود على سبيل المثال سوف اطرح
لك بعض المعطيات التي قدمتها منظمات دوليه
ومنظمات تقارير الامم المتحده لكي ا نشرح
الواقع الذي يجري في حمص تقريبا هناك اكثر
من 800,000 من سكان حمص بين نازح ولاجئ
ومقتل من اراضيه اي نازح داخليا و وفي
الخارج على على سبيل المثال تاتي حمص في
المرتبه الاولى من ناحيه الدمار بمعدل 25%
من حمص مدمر بشكل كامل بحاجه الى اعاده
تجريف واعاده بناء من من الجديد في حمص
بحسب بحسب تقارير المنظمات الح الدوليه
اكبر حالات العنف الجنسي وكان واشارت
التقارير بشكل الى وجود سلوك ممنهج للعنف
الجنسي لاجبار وترويع السكان من اجل هجر
مناطقهم باتجاه ما تبقى من قسم الاخير في
حمص في ريف حمص وهو الريف الشمالي
فجا هذه المعطيات كلها حقيقه تصوب في خانه
في خانه تغيير ديموغرافي ممنهج للسكان في
حمص انا انا لا النظام يرى سكان حمص
بوصفهم ثوار وعلى الرغم من ان بعض قادته
يعامل على اساس على اساس طائفي لكن ما
يريده النظام هو اخلاء حمص التي انتفضت عن
بكره ابيها بدايه الثوره عن هذا التقدم
وعن هذه الرمزيه بالنسبه لمدينه حمس وه
سؤالي موجه للاستاذ فيصل عبد الساتر هل
تعتقد بان هذا التقدم ما تحقق هو بشكل
حاسم ام بشكل
ظرفي لا طبعا يعني هناك نيه لدى الدوله
السوريه والجيش العربي السوري ان ينتهي من
كل البؤر المتوتره والبؤر الامنيه التي
تشكل قلقا كبيرا على حياه الاهالي سواء في
حمص او في غير حمص ومن قال ان الشعب في
حمص هو يوالي يعني مثل هذه التنظيمات ومثل
هذه المجموعات المسلحه يعني عندما نسمع
احد احد الضيوف لديكم في قناه الجزيره او
في قنوات اخرى يتحدث وكانه لديه يعني
صلاحيه مطلقه التحدث باسم الشعب السوري
الشعب السوري لو لم يكن هناك اكثريه واضحه
مع الد في سوريا لقلنا ان هناك العديد من
الامور قد تغيرت وتبدلت حلب هذه التي
تعتبر اكبر
مدينه اذا اردنا ان نتكلم بهذه اللغه
المطبق على كلامك ايضا المقياس
نفسه ربما ربما انا لا اقول ان كلامي منزل
انا اقول ان كلامي ايضا تحت النقد يجب ان
يكون هناك دائما نقد لكن عندما نتحدث
بالموضوع الطائفي والمذهبي يجب علينا
جميعا ان نبتعد على هذه اللغه لانها كلفت
كثيرا في العالم العربي وعندما نتحدث عن
اكثري وعن اقيات علينا ان نتجه الى اللعبه
الديمقراطيه التي تحسم الامور في
الانتخابات لكن ان تقوم بجماعات مسلحه
بالعنف ثم تقول ان هناك تغييرا ديموغرافيا
ما الذي يستطيع فعله النظام في سوريا في
تغيير محافظه مساحتها مساحتها 40,000 م
مربع يعني هي اربع مرات اكثر من لبنان عن
ماذا نتحدث عن اي عن اي ماده ممكن ان تحدث
تغييرا ديموغرافيا في حمص او في حلب او في
دمشق هذا كلام يعني اصبح يعني شيئا يعني
مقيتا عندما نتحدث عنه لو لم يكن هناك
اكثريه من الشعب السوري من كل الطوائف ومن
كل المذاهب توالي هذه الدوله لما استطاعت
هذه الدوله ان تصمت ثلاث سنوات امام حرب
تقودها دول بواسطه جماعات مسلحه داخل
اراضي سوريا ثلاث سنوات لاستطاعت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تفعل شيئا في سوريا
وما استطاعت تركيا ان تفعل شيء في سوريا
ولا السعوديه ولا قطر ولا الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولا اي دوله في العالم استطاعت
ان تغير موازين القو فقط ولا ايران ولا
حزب الله ولا روسيا ايضا هذا الكلام يواجه
ذاك فقط حتى نختم استاذ حمزه
محيح صحيح لكن اراده الشعب السوري هي التي
هي التي غيرت الم هل ترى هذا التقدم بانه
حاسم ام ظرفي هلا فيما يتعلق بالتقدم على
ال هو حاسم بالنسبه للنظام على على المدى
المنظور لكن النظام الذي يحاول يحاول
تقسيم سوريا وتفريعها الى مناطق عسكريه
مختلفه بحيث يدير كل منطقه على حداه هي
جبهات مشتعله بشكل الان تغير الموازين في
القلمون وفي حمص لصالح النظام منذ سبعه
منذ سبعه نيسان وحتى الان تغير غيرت
الموازين بشكل كامل لصالح قوات المعارضه
في حلب وتتغير بشكل كبير في في جبهه خان
خان شيخون ومورك في في ريف حماء الشمالي
وتتغير ايضا في جبهه دير الزور وبالتالي
وبالتالي الموازين ليست ثابته باي حال من
الاحوال وهي اقرب الثوره السوريه اصبحت
اقرب الى حرب تحرير وبالتالي لن تكون
اشكرك اشكرك ادركنا الوقت الاستاذ حمزه
المصطفى الباحث في المركز العربي للابحاث
ودراسه الس شكرا جزيلا لك ما اشكر ضيفي من
بيروت الكاتب الصحفي فيصل عبد الساتر
وكذلك ضيفي عبر سكايب من حي الوعر في حمص
الناشط الحقوقي محمد الحميد بذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه